>> A CON, A BELIEF ARTIST, A
MUTT WHO DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT, TALKS AND WANTS
TO PUNCH PEOPLE IN THE FACE?
I'D LIKE TO PUNCH HIM IN THE
FACE.
BABY IN CHIEF HAS -- [BLEEP] IN
CHIEF I CALL HIM.
>> I REMEMBER THE TONYS WHERE HE
CAME UP AND CURSED, [BLEEP] ON
THE [BLEEP] --
THIS GUY IS LIKE A GANGSTER.
>> Laura: THIS IS ROBERT
DE NIRO IN ONE OF HIS PROFANITY
LACED RANTS, AND ON FOX NEWS.
ROBERT DE NIRO WAS HIT WITH A
$120 MILLION HARASSMENT LAWSUIT.
I WILL BE THE FIRST TO TELL YOU
THAT ANYONE CAN SUE.
IN THIS CASE, THE NERO'S
ASSISTANT HAS EVIDENCE IN THE
FORM OF AT LEAST AN ANGRY
VOICE MAIL.
>> YOU [BLEEP] DON'T ANSWER MY
CALLS!
HOW DARE YOU?
YOU ARE AGAINST ME!
YOU [BLEEP], YOU ARE HISTORY.
I DIDN'T GET A SINGLE THING I
NEED, RIGHT NOW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN LESS THAN 24 HOURS
QUICK MIKE YOU'VE GOT TO BE
[BLEEP] KIDDING ME, YOU SPOILED
BRAT!
>> Laura: GOOD ACTING!
EXCEPT, IT'S NOT.
OUR QUESTION TONIGHT, HAS A
TRUMP BROKEN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
THE NERO LIVES IN YORK, HE'S NOT
IN HOLLYWOOD, BUT YOU'VE GOT MY
POINT.
HERE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION,
ACTOR ROBERT DOBBIE.
PEOPLE SEEM THEY ARE REALLY
UNHINGED WHETHER THEY ARE
CHELSEA HANDLER SAID SHE NEEDED
THERAPY LAST MAY.
DOESN'T LIKE TO BE CRITICIZED,
ALL THESE PEOPLE GO NUTS.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
LAURA.
IT'S INTERESTING.
I THINK THE VITRIOL THAT DE NIRO
IS FEELING DONALD TRUMP MUST
COME FROM SOME MAY BE SOME
REAL ESTATE DEAL IN NEW YORK
YEARS AGO, BECAUSE IT SEEMS KIND
OF UNJUSTIFIED IN A CERTAIN WAY.
I MEAN, SINCE HE BECAME
PRESIDENT, TRUMP HAS BEEN UNDER
ATTACK, AS WE ALL KNOW, WITH
THIS COLLUSION, AND IT'S
MISPLACED ANGER.
WHEN HE SAYS SOMETHING LIKE THAT
TO THE REST OF THE NATION, WHAT
HE SAID ON CNN AT THEM, YOU'VE
GOT 60 MILLION PLUS PEOPLE
THAT -- NOW, THE NERO IS A GREAT
ACTOR, GREAT ARTIST, REVERED
AROUND THE WORLD, AND FOR HIM
TO SAY THE PRESIDENT IS ACTING
LIKE A GANGSTER WHEN IF YOU
LISTEN TO SOME OF THE JUNK AUDIO
RECORDINGS, IT SOUNDS A LITTLE
BIT LIKE THAT.
>> Laura: DO YOU KNOW WHAT I
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH, ROBERT?
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO SPEAK
OUT.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO SAY WE
DON'T CARE WHAT YOU SAY.
EVERYONE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO SAY
WHAT THEY WANT.
THAT'S FREE SPEECH.
WHAT I WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHEN
THEY ARE CRITICIZED, YOU CAN'T
CRITICIZE ME!
I'M A PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE!
I'M AN ACTOR!
LIKE, HEY, YOU WANT TO STEP IN
THE ARENA OF POLITICS, STEP IN.
LET'S DO IT.
WHY DON'T YOU COME ON THE SHOW
AND TRY THAT NONSENSE WITH
SOMEONE LIKE ME AND WE'LL HAVE A
REAL CONVERSATION.
BUT YOU HIDE BEHIND THESE PUP
INTERVIEWS BEHIND PEOPLE WERE
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEY
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEA
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEE
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEB
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THES
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEC
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEL
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEY
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEW
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THER
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEH
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEP
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEN
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEG
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THEA
PEOPLE SUCK UP TO YOU 24/7, THET
HIS FEET AT THAT INTERVIEW.
>> THEY GIVE HIM FEED LINES AND
THE COURAGE TO SAY THAT KIND OF
STUFF INSTEAD A CONFRONTATION.
I SAW AN INTERVIEW WITH DINERO,
HE WAS ON STAGE AND PEOPLE WENT
TO CHEERING OR APPLYING
APPLAUDING.
HE SAID, COME ON, LET'S APPLAUD
THIS.
IT WAS BASHING TRUMP, IT WAS
LIKE IT WAS REQUIRED TO STAND UP
AND APPLAUD IN TRUMP BASHING.
THERE'S A BUBBLE IN HOLLYWOOD, A
BUBBLE IN NEW YORK AND THE
WEST COAST, THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN INSIDE BOTH BUBBLES AND
HE'S BURSTING IT FROM INSIDE.
WITH THAT, THEY ARE SUCKING
OXYGEN.
THEY ARE PANICKING BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT CATCH A BREATH.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
CHRISTIE ALLY THE OTHER DAY JUST
MENTION SOMETHING AND I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN HOLLYWOOD HAS
BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH THIS.
HOW MANY YEARS ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE WITH THIS COLLUSION?
NOW TALKING ABOUT SCHIFF MAKING